was nun frau merkel die koalition einigt
sich auf ein milliardenschweres
konjunkturprogramm zur bekämpfung der
korona folgen und sie landen vor allem
mit der absenkung der mehrwertsteuer
einen wirklichen überraschungscoup heute
nacht aber viele fragen sich auch woher
kommen eigentlich diese vielen vielen
milliarden werden unsere kinder und
enkel einmal die zeche für ihre corona
politik zahlen müssen
naja wir müssen uns ja fragen in welcher
situation sind wir und wir haben die
schwierigste wirtschaftliche lage die
schwerste krise seit bestehen der
bundesrepublik deutschland wir haben
gestern gehört über sieben millionen
menschen sind in kurzarbeit
und man stelle sich mal vor die werden
arbeitslos und gott sei dank haben wir
dieses instrument und da mussten wir
mutig reagieren um dem etwas entgegen zu
setzen denn wir wollen ja schnell
möglichst zu unserem wohlstand zurück
und das heißt menschen müssen kaufen
können und wenn der sozial entlasten
wollen dann ist eine kurzfristige
senkung der mehrwertsteuer genau richtig
und zwar auch zeitlich befristet damit
dann auch wirklich die wirtschaft wieder
in gang kommt und trotzdem frau merkel
sind plötzlich viele milliarden da die
für andere zwecke an den letzten jahren
gefehlt haben für bildung für soziales
fürs klima ich finde sie mal
grundsätzlich fragen ist das nach 15
jahren kanzlerschaft angela merkel nun
eine abkehr von dem was sie bisher
geleitet hat in der wirtschaftspolitik
in der finanzpolitik ist erstmal so
stadt schwäbische hausfrau statt
schwarzer 0 enden sie plötzlich als
schulden kanzlerin naja ich sage ja die
muss gucken warum macht man etwas und
ich bin sehr froh dass wir die viele
kritik ausgehalten haben dass wir nun
immer auf einen ausgeglichenen haushalt
gesetzt haben das setzt uns heute in die
lage genau
auch jetzt handeln zu können aber sie
haben vollkommen recht das ist nicht
geld was wir auf der hohen kante hatten
sondern das ist geld was wir als
schulden aufnehmen und wir glauben
trotzdem dass es richtig eine generation
bezeichnet muss das von späteren
generationen bezahlt werden muss und
deshalb bin ich so froh dass in den
jahren wo es uns gut ging wo wir solche
probleme wie ein solches virus nicht
hatten wir eben nicht einfach geld
ausgegeben haben sondern wo wir da sogar
schulden
reduzieren konnten wenn man es prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes sieht wir
sind wieder unter die geforderte grenze
gekommen nach der wirtschafts und
finanzkrise unter die 60 prozent und
deshalb können wir heute handeln aber
wir müssen natürlich auch schauen wir
können nicht einfach irgendwie handeln
und wir können noch nicht grenzenlos
handeln das heißt wir müssen die
wirtschaft in gang bekommen damit
arbeitsplätze entstehen und menschen
sich auch etwas leistung und die leute
sollen was ausgeben absenkung der
mehrwertsteuer das war durchaus eine
überraschung gestern auch davon
profitiert in der tat jeder allerdings
ja auch alle wirtschaftszweige auch die
alten technologien kamen schon auf den
klimaschutz ist dass am ende doch so ein
stückchen abwrackprämie durch die
hintertür dann auch denn davon
profitieren dann ja auch
verbrennungsmotoren
nein es ist im grunde etwas wo wir auf
die entscheidungskraft der bürgerinnen
und bürger setzen sie werden sich
entscheiden ob sie sich ein fahrrad
kaufen ob sie sich ein elektroauto
kaufen ob sie sich ein anderes auto
kaufen aber wir trauen den menschen das
zu dass sie wissen was sie sich
anschaffen wollen und wir entlasten ja
auch den unteren mehrwertsteuersatz das
heißt also auch gerade diejenigen die
sehr viel rechnen müssen bei den
täglichen bedarf werden davon
profitieren und wir fördern und da
setzen wir den akzent dann neue
mobilität also e-autos hybridautos noch
deutlicher als dies bisher getan haben
das heißt da sagen wir den menschen will
euch dafür entscheidet liegt der staat
noch eine schippe drauf und das war ja
in der tat auch der anspruch dieses
paket das es eben nicht nur kurzfristig
sein soll sondern auch nachhaltig wirken
soll deshalb noch mal die nachfrage
hätte man beim punkt klimaschutz nicht
doch mutiger sein sein müssen als sie es
sind sie nehmen das für sich in anspruch
aber hätte man nicht etwa hilfen stärker
noch an ökologische kriterien binden
müssen als voraussetzung ist es nun doch
dann am ende eine mogelpackung nein das
finde ich nicht wir haben maßnahmen die
sehr schnell wirken müssen
und das bedeutet 2020/2021 das ist die
große summe von den 130 milliarden sind
das etwa 80 die sehr sehr schnell in
diesen beiden jahren wirken müssen und
da
wir anreize zum austausch der flotte zum
beispiel von sozialdiensten für die neue
mobilität für die bahn für alle bereiche
der verkehrsträger nicht nur für das
auto für nutzfahrzeuge für öffentlichen
personennahverkehr
da setzen wir anreize für die
digitalisierung zum beispiel der schulen
für den ausbau von 5 g das heißt wir
verbinden kurzfristiges handeln sonst
ist es kein konjunkturprogramm dann ist
das normales handeln mit dem mit der
tatsache dass wir in die neuen
entwicklungen investieren und das klima
und das es digitalisierung das sind die
beiden großen umbrüche unseres
wirtschaftens und dann setzen wir darauf
dass wir eben auch in forschung
entwicklung stärker werden neue
energieformen zum beispiel und wir
schaffen verlässlichkeit auch für die
wirtschaft und für die bürgerinnen und
bürger mit den stromkosten und mit den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen wir geben
hier auch ein versprechen ab keine
sozialleistungen werden gekürzt
aber die beiträge steigen auch nicht
auch das ist für familien wichtig aber
auch für unternehmen ganz wichtig sie
setzen auf den verbraucher so zu sagen
frau merkel auf die unternehmen und
darauf dass der handel natürlich auch
das weiter gibt was jetzt an
mehrwertsteuerabsenkung geplant ist
schließen sie denn schon heute aus wenn
dieses steuergeschenk für alle das ist
es ja irgendwie nicht funktioniert wenn
die konjunktur dann nicht ab springt das
nicht anspringt dass sich diese
maßnahmen eventuell auch verlängern
könnten ins nächste jahr oder ist das
ein stichtag 31 12 20 damit schluss das
ist für mich ein stichtag
wir können natürlich überhaupt nicht
ganz genau wissen wie wird sich die
panini weiterentwickeln da bleibt immer
eine gewisse unsicherheit aber wir
setzen darauf dass diese
mehrwertsteuersenkung ausläuft und dass
sie ein kurzfristiger impuls ist und
dass dieses auch hilft und dass es auch
weiter gegeben wird ich meine soziale
marktwirtschaft so wir leben in einem
freiheitlichen in einer freiheitlichen
gesellschaft da ist es immer so dass wir
darauf setzen dass alle akteure wollen
dass es dieser gesellschaft gut geht die
arbeitnehmerinnen arbeitnehmer die
familien die unternehmer und der staat
flankiert das und es ist jetzt eine zeit
wo der staat mehr tun muss als er
normalerweise gibt das ganze paket kann
ja in der tat nur dann so
hilfreich sein und eine wirkung erzielen
wenn eben keine zweite welle kommt keine
starke zweite welle kommt sie sagt
selber dass ist unkalkulierbar ein
bisschen immer noch für sie tatsächlich
auch angesichts dieser vielen
lockerungen die wir jetzt sehen viele
leute denken ja eigentlich haben wir es
hinter uns
gehen ihnen die öffnungen jetzt überall
zu weit
nein ich glaube dass wir grund maßnahmen
einhalten müssen und da werde ich
unruhig wenn zum beispiel menschen
glauben wir brauchen die abstands
maßnahmen nicht mehr die brauchen wir
ein meter fünfzig dort wo man die nicht
einhalten kann maske tragen das ist
absolut notwendig und das ist nicht nur
für mich selber notwendig sondern es ist
auch für andere notwendig also ich
schütze auch meine mitmenschen und das
wird so lange bleiben solange wir keinen
impfstoff haben und kein medikament
haben und zweitens sind wir natürlich
jeden tag klüger was das virus anbelangt
was die bekämpfung anbelangt wir sehen
jetzt ja geradezu bilderbuch artig denn
wir sagen nicht sehen
dann sagt man erst mal meine güte warum
denn nicht singen aber dann sehen sie
dort vor gesungen wurde dort wo
vielleicht man eng zusammen gesessen hat
in einer bar
dort wo arbeitsbedingungen nicht so sind
dass man diesen abstand einhalten kann
da passieren genau jetzt diese infektion
dass wir gestern gemacht haben und das
war mir ganz wichtig wir haben den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst gestärkt
der war nicht auf der höhe der zeit der
arbeiten menschen die sind unglaublich
motiviert aber wirklich nicht immer mit
der besten edv ausgestattet nicht die
digitalisierung mitgemacht nicht so gut
bezahlt wie ich mir das wünsche und das
haben wir jetzt in die hand genommen und
diese menschen in den öffentlichen
gesundheitsämtern den kommt jetzt eine
zentrale bedeutung zu nämlich ob man die
kontakte nach verfolgen mit handel am
ende davon zeugen wenn man das kann und
wir können es im augenblick bei den
infektionszahlen dann haben wir es unter
kontrolle und dann muss man lieber lokal
wie man es jetzt in götting gemacht hat
noch mal was schließen als dass man die
ganze das ganze land wieder in die
situation bringen und die vorsicht muss
weiterhin sein sonst am ende dann aber
eben doch die ministerpräsidenten zu
früh zu weit gegangen weil das wirkt
sich auch psychologisch aus mehr
lockerungen dann werden die leute auch
leichtsinniger vielleicht auch zu weit
gegangen weil ihnen am
die autorität gefehlt hat zu sagen jetzt
macht mal darum geht es nicht der bund
beobachtet das ja sehr genau und wir
sind auch am 17 juni schon wieder
zusammen mit dem ministerpräsidenten wir
sind ein föderaler staat das ist
manchmal kompliziert aber das hat unterm
strich auch vorteile weil natürlich
lokal auch sehr viel unterschiedlicher
reagiert wäre aber wer weiß haben sie
sich schon mein heimatland mein
heimatland zum beispiel hat in vielen
landkreisen überhaupt keine infektion
mehr in bayern war das anders
wir haben die absprache mit einander die
grundregeln einzuhalten
und wir haben die absprache miteinander
wenn etwas sich schlecht entwickeln
würde dann würden wir auch reagieren und
jetzt sage ich mal das gibt bereiche
öffnung der schulen zum beispiel und der
kitas das gehört zu den schwersten was
es gibt und da die richtige entscheidung
zu treffen wo man noch nicht mal die
wissenschaftlichen grundlagen so hat
dass man sagen kann ich kann es machen
aber ich kann es nicht machen da wird
unheimlich viel mühe und arbeit
reingesteckt dass man den richtigen weg
findet der lernen sicherlich auch
bundesländer wie gegenseitig von den
erfahrungen und vielfalt kann ja uns
manchmal auch schneller voranbringen
frau bundeskanzlerin um diese zweite
welle zu vermeiden sie haben das
stichwort eben genannt die gefahr
besteht immer noch ich fragte sie auch
ganz persönlich wie viel angst haben sie
davor und vielleicht politisch wenn sie
kommt wie groß ist unser arsenal- dann
noch nochmal zu schießen noch mal mit
zuviel milliarden und billionen
ich glaube nicht dass es sich genauso
wiederholt wie es war wir können viel
eher reagieren wenn wir uns an das was
wir vereinbart haben halten 50
infektionen in sieben tagen pro 100000
einwohner dann muss geguckt werden zum
beispiel das bundesland berlin in dem ja
manchmal auch ganz schöne verstöße
passieren das muss man sagen da da hat
man ampeln eingeführt wenn der faktor zu
groß ist oder wenn die bettenzahl
in gefahr geraten ich habe
schauen sie angst ist das falsche wort
ich bin unglaublich aufmerksam dass
immer zu beobachten tag für tag
solange dieses virus ist nicht
verschwunden auch wenn wir es nicht
sehen und es ist eine demokratische
zumutung also ich fühle mich auch mit
einer zumutung konfrontiert wie alle
menschen
aber wir müssen ja klug reagieren und
ich habe ein ziel das wir nicht eine
gesellschaft werden bei der die jungen
sozusagen sich frei bewegen können und
die älteren werden sozusagen zuhause
gelassen und dürfen sich nicht mehr
sehen lassen weil sie vielleicht etwas
gefährdet da sind oder menschen mit
vorerkrankungen behinderte und das wird
jetzt die große aufgabe allen menschen
in dieser neuen zeit mit dem virus einen
lebensraum zu geben dass nicht einige
gar nicht mehr auftreten
es kann nicht die gesellschaft die erste
reise will hier ein bisschen die augen
wie viel an milliarden ja zu freigesetzt
wird hierzulande in deutschland national
aber eben auch auf europäischer ebene
die eu ist zum zum ersten mal in der
lage eigene schulden in milliardenhöhe
zu ermöglichen
die eu-kommission kann das machen und
viele fragen sich ist dass am ende dann
nicht doch das wofür sie immer gekämpft
haben da wogegen sie immer gekämpft
haben nämlich der einstieg in eine
gemeinschafts verschuldung in eine art
transferunion
also erstmal die milliarden sind nicht
so vorhanden
die ziehen wir nicht aus einem schrank
wo wir sie weggesperrt hätten vor den
menschen für sich
da wir nehmen schulden auf und die frage
es war nehme ich schulden auch dann wenn
ich glaube dass ich damit für die
zukunft etwas besseres schaffe als wenn
ich jetzt normal weiterleben würde dann
ist es nicht normal
und diese herausforderung mit diesem
virus die hat es ja keiner von uns
gewünscht die ist über uns gekommen und
in sofern dieser land in der lage eine
ganz besondere und besondere situationen
erfordern besondere maßnahmen aber
trotzdem das geht ja um die länder frau
merkel jetzt ich war gerade mal um die
eu möchte ich gerne noch mal darauf
zurückkommen denn wir erlauben nicht
einfach der kommission schulden zu
machen sondern dienen
nationalen parlamente jedes einzelne
parlament von jedem mitgliedstaat muss
der eu die erlaubnis geben dass sie bis
zu einer bestimmten obergrenze geld
aufnehmen darf also sich verschulden
kann mit einem klaren rückzahlbar
wann und wie das dann auch wieder
zurückgezahlt wird und das ist im rahmen
der verträge möglich und weil eben
außergewöhnliche situation auch
außergewöhnliches handeln erfordern
glaube ich dass das gut investiertes
geld ist aber auch hier nicht etwas was
wir irgendwo hatten sondern was auch
eine hoffnung auf die zukunft ist dass
wir das zurück sein aber es geht auch um
die mitgliedsländer der eu geht zum
beispiel um besonders betroffene länder
wie spanien und italien und es gibt
schon leute die sagen im grunde fehlen
klare bedingungen nachdem diese mittel
jetzt vergeben werden
wie hoch ist die gefahr bei allem guten
willen von merkel bei allem einsatz für
europa wie hoch ist die gefahr dass hier
milliarden verbrannt werden ohne dass in
diesen ländern etwas ändert zb die
schlechte verwaltung des staates in
italien also das glaube ich haben wir
schon recht gut im griff denn was ist
das ziel vielleicht noch mal das ziel
ist dass die schäden die durch das virus
entstanden sind ja nicht durch schlechte
politik entstanden sind sondern sie sind
durch eine naturkatastrophe durch ein
naturereignis sozusagen entstanden und
jetzt wollen wir dass die eu nicht
sozusagen viel unterschiedlicher aus
dieser krise heraus kommt einfach durch
etwas was keiner verschuldet hat und
dazu leistet dass einen beitrag und
natürlich hat der italienische
ministerpräsident da würde ich auch sehr
froh darüber gesagt wir müssen unser
regierungshandeln auch verändern wir
müssen bürokratie abbauen
er wird auch hat einen plan vorgelegt
wie er sein land verändern will aber
wichtig ist doch wir haben die kontrolle
dass der deutsche bundestag wird zum
schluss darüber bestimmen wie dieses
geld ausgegeben wird die kommission hat
jetzt einen vorschlag gemacht den werden
wir analysieren das werden wir
verhandeln das werden harte gespräche
werden und dann wird das parlament offen
darüber debattieren und sagen haben wir
genug kontrolle geht das in die richtige
richtung und das darf natürlich nicht
einfach budget finanzierung seien für
haushaltslöcher sondern es müssen kluge
investitionen seien
die alle länder nach vorne zu unserer
sendung gehört frau bundeskanzler sie
kennen das schon die satz ergänzung wir
geben ein halbsatz vor und wir bitten
sie ihn möglichst kurz zu ergänzen und
der erste halbsatz lautet leben mit
corona heißt für mich ganz persönlich
mit sehr vielen einschränkungen auch zu
leben ich kann viel weniger menschen
treffen persönlich und ich erlebe das
erlebnis von videokonferenzen wie viele
andere glaube ich auch meinen
sommerurlaubs ziel in diesem jahr ist
deutschland das der rat der virologen in
meiner corona politik eine zu große
rolle gespielt hat dass vereine ich bin
dankbar dass deutschland so tolle
forscher hat die wir fragen konnten und
die den ersten test entwickelt haben und
wie immer in der wissenschaft ich kenne
das ja aus meiner früheren zeit vor der
politik gibt es unterschiedliche
meinungen gibt es jeden tag neue
entdeckungen und deshalb habe ich gerne
den rat der wissenschaftler aber die
politische entscheidung die fällen wir
und das kann man nicht vermischen
nochmal zum halbsatz dass markus söder
inzwischen von vielen als
kanzlerkandidat gesehen wird lese ich in
der zeitung
der schwierigste moment in dieser krise
war für mich die einschränkung ich lebe
jetzt 30 jahre wir haben 30 jahre
deutsche einheit im vereinten
deutschland und dann menschen zu sagen
ihr müsst zu hause bleiben es gibt
ostern keine gottesdienste
ihr könnt nicht mehr ins theater gehen
die künstler können nicht auftreten
die grenzen werden kontrolliert es darf
keine touristischen reisen geben das war
das schwerste
mit einem impfstoff gegen korona rechne
ich hoffentlich bald aber und sagen alle
experten unter einem jahr bis 18 monaten
ist nichts zu machen und wir dürfen auch
nicht zum schluss alle tests die man
machen muss und alle erprobungen
so verkürzen das dann wieder neue
schäden entstehen bei uns ganze region
ins ausland die usa werden seit tagen
von demonstrationen gegen rassismus und
polizeigewalt erschüttert wie viel
anteil an diese eskalation trägt nach
ihrer einschätzung donald trump der
präsident zum beispiel durch seine
gewalt verherrlichten tweets an dieser
entwicklung also erst einmal ist dieser
mord an george j etwas ganz ganz
schreckliches rassismus ist etwas
schreckliches und die gesellschaft in
den vereinigten staaten ist sehr
polarisiert ich glaube oder meine
ansprüche sind immer an politik dass man
versucht auch zusammenzubringen und zu
versöhnen
das tut er das nicht ja was sich den
preis mit dem präsidenten gespräche
darüber spreche ich in der
öffentlichkeit nicht aber ich sage mal
dieses land ist sehr polarisiert und ich
kann nur hoffen dass man zusammenfindet
ich bin froh dass viele dazu ihren
beitrag auch eine rolle wie
polarisierung
ich glaube dass der politikstil schon
ein sehr kontroverser ist das ist klar
aber ich möchte hier keine eins zu eins
dinge machen rassismus hat es zu allen
zeiten gegeben aber leider gibt es ihnen
auch bei uns und jetzt kehren wir mal
vor unserer eigenen haustür und hoffen
dass auch in den vereinigten staaten
sich genug menschen finden die einfach
friedliche demonstration sie gleichwohl
noch vertrauen in diesem amerikanischen
präsidenten ich arbeite zusammen mit den
gewählten präsidenten auf der welt und
natürlich auch mit dem amerikanischen
und ich hoffe dass es gelingt das land
gut zu befrieden haben uns ganz am ende
noch mal die frage nach vier monaten
corona krise so lange ist es ja
mittlerweile und angesichts der immer
klarer werdenden kosten
es geht in die millionen stellen sie
sich manchmal die frage waren die
maßnahmen die richtigen waren sie
angemessen oder fragen sie sich manchmal
etwas zu viel war es zu weitgehend also
die alle schritte die ich tue die
hinterfragt man natürlich aber ich würde
im rückblick sagen dass wir
vergleichsweise gut durch diese
situation gekommen sind bei uns waren
die parks nicht gespart bei uns musste
man nicht durfte man nicht nur eine
stunde am tag aus dem haus wie zum
beispiel in unserem nachbarland
frankreich
bei uns gab es keine überforderung des
gesundheitswesens bei uns konnte man
sich den ganzen tag frei bewegen in
spanien waren
kinder sechs wochen sechs wochen nicht
einmal aus dem haus gegangen
in der türkei wenn ich mir das anschaue
zum beispiel müssen ältere menschen über
65 können vier stunden raus also ich
würde sagen wir können auch ein stück
dankbar sein dass wir glaube ich einen
ganz guten weg gefunden haben und
deshalb sage ich ja manchmal auch wir
dürfen uns jetzt nicht verspielen das
wäre schade ist nämlich noch nicht zu
ende und das fordert ja vielleicht auch
etwas von ihnen denken sie manchmal
darüber nach dass sie in verantwortung
bleiben müssen vielleicht auch dann für
eine nächste kanzlerkandidatur zur
verfügung stehen nein wirklich nicht
dass nein steht also aber ganz fest
das war was nun frau merkel herzlichen
dank für den besuch hier bei uns im
programm geht es jetzt weiter mit notruf
hafenkante
vielen dank für ihr interesse tschüss
[Musik]